ALL RIGHT.
EVERY EXPERIMENT NEEDS
A CONTROL.
NOW, RIGHT
NOW, ME AND JOHN
ARE IN A BARBER SHOP
IN HARLEM.
EVERYONE HERE
IS EITHER BLACK OR LATINO.
LET'S SEE HOW ELECTRIC GUITAR
WORKS ON THEM.
READY, JOHN ?
YEAH.
OKAY, OKAY, GO, GO.
♪♪
HEY, YO !
SHUT THE F**K UP !
OKAY, OKAY.
THAT WENT PRETTY MUCH
HOW I EXPECTED.
NOW, LET'S SEE HOW
THE BLACKS RESPOND TO DRUMS.
( drum roll )
QUESTLOVE, GO.
(playing drums)
AHH... YEAH !
YEAH !
UNH !
SPIT SOMETHIN', SPIT
SOMETHIN', SPIT SOMETHIN'.
♪ YO, YO ♪
♪ I'M DOWN WITH
ANY SEX OR ANY RACE ♪
♪ IF YOU WERE BEATIN' ME ♪
♪ IT'S LIKE BILLY CRYSTAL
PLAYIN' SCARFACE ♪
♪ AND I CAN'T
SEE IT, BLIND TO THE EYES ♪
♪ I CAME UP IN YOUR FACE,
OOPS, POW, SURPRISE ♪
OH !
YEAH !
WHOO !
WHOO, THAT
WORKED LIKE GANGBUSTERS !
BUT I STILL HAPPENED
TO NOTICE,
SOME OF THE LATIN
PEOPLE WERE NODDING THEIR HEADS,
BUT THEY WEREN'T REALLY
FEELING IT
AS MUCH AS
I THOUGHT THEY WOULD.
BUT I THINK I GOT
THE REMEDY.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF
I INCORPORATED WITHIN THAT
AN ELECTRIC PIANO ?
SANCHEZ, GO !
(playing piano)
(drums playing Latin beat)
ALL RIGHT,
THIS IS GOING GREAT.
NOW I'M GONNA KICK IT UP A
NOTCH, WATCH THIS.
( shouting
in Spanish gibbberish )
♪ YI, YI, YI, YI,
YI, YI, YI ♪
♪ YI, YI, YI,
YI, YI, YI, YI ♪
AY, CARAMBA !
OLE !
( music ends )
HEY, GUYS, HAVE A GOOD DAY.
SORRY FOR INTERRUPTING.